46 so this morning we're trying to make
your holiday cooking just a skosh easier
a little bit we're sharing some simple
family-friendly holiday recipes for
joining us live from their own home to
show us what's cooking hi Candace
good morning
morning folks we've just made these
delicious raviolis well I can't take too
much credit for it and it's actually a
lot more simple than you think you guys
can make this with your kiddos and I
have the junior chefs here Zoey daily
are going to help us shortly to prove it
they've gone to cooking classes with the
one at the only Katie and Nicholas Rizzo
thank you so much for joining us this
morning okay walk us through this really
quickly so this is the Italian machine
okay and then just like you can just put
it in those two rolls okay you guys I am
making some pasta okay one I got skills
I got skills okay so got that part going
like take it out nice nice okay same
same simple enough okay there you go so
then what do you do next the next you
take the filling okay and then just spy
bit awesome okay I'm gonna do that tell
me a little bit about the cooking
classes really quickly Katie absolutely
so uh we have eight week cooking courses
that we hold here at the house
um this next course coming up actually
it's starting in January and we have two
classes for six to 12 year olds and one
from 13 to team and we're going to be
doing all Italian Cuisines so the eight
weeks of just Italian cuisine it's gonna
be so much fun and we cannot wait for it
um so actually two of these kiddos or
three of these kiddos are going to be in
it and we're so we're so amped so okay
so the next step here I'm doing this now
putting a little water through okay and
as you can see the kids are doing it
because they're a lot better at this you
guys got to tell me it's it's a class
easy is it simple do they make it easy
for you guys yeah yeah okay well it
looks like you guys are doing a good job
so they're gonna roll this up thank you
so much Katie Nicholas and you guys you
guys ready to eat really give it a try
really quickly put a little cheese on it
yes that's the of course you guys will
get all the details about the recipes
and how to possibly put these folks for
New Year's Eve they're gonna be relaxing
for Christmas but maybe for New Year's
Eve on their website 8newsnow.com all
right guys gonna do some eating go enjoy
the rest of your morning
Candace what's in the ravioli what was
the filling right is that ricotta cheese
oh you're right right what is the
filling uh it's just ricotta and spinach
yeah that's actually an important thing
to add John you were absolutely right
you can find those recipes on our
website guys either way it looks
absolutely delicious oh I could have
ravioli any time of the day my